SBN HC and have included representatives
from the american institute for
conservation and the council for library
and information resources to build our
program we've sought speakers from a
variety of venues and some of them
unfamiliar to us including people from
the National Gallery the Metropolitan
Museum of Art the British Museum and of
course many of our own colleagues in the
Natural History community we've pursued
the very practitioners of Natural
History Collection management
conservators collection managers
digitization specialists informatics
specialists and we've also pursued
senior administrators and senior
administrators from government
universities and freestanding museums we
have delegates from approximately 15
countries and about 156 abstract
submitted to this meeting and I'll tell
you what I'm really looking forward to
Saturday when this meeting is over we
have a number of topical sessions in
this meeting that will focus on best
practices and the promotion of
collection care such as the AIC
sponsored stash project and yet other
sessions that will address technological
innovations such as demo camp an
interactive session that an interactive
session with live demonstrations of
software innovation got to be honest
none of these meetings can be successful
without a band of volunteers a host
committee my co-chair Susan butts who by
the end of last week we were calling her
general butts but we also have sponsors
and we also have vendors and we have a
huge trade show this year we had 45
companies and institutions sponsor very
asked varying aspects of the meeting
from our topical sessions our workshops
are social events such as the icebreaker
last night with their support we've been
able to keep the cost of our meeting at
a reasonable and affordable level for
broad participation from the Natural
History community but one thing I do is
I encourage you all to spend time in our
exhibition tradeshow we have 40 vendors
in there or so don't just go and pick up
the the trinkets and stuff they bring
but share with them your ideas your
thoughts for product development what do
we need in the community these are the
guys that have the the resources to
develop these products and we can't be
shy about sharing ideas and thoughts
this is the best thing about SB NHC is
that we share our ideas so let's
continue to do that in particular though
I'd like to thank the yellow Institute
for the preservation of cultural
heritage and Delta design before last
meetings last year's meeting was over in
California Bruce Danielson from Delta
design comes up with his good old Kansas
twang and says Tim you just let me know
what you need i'll be your diamond
sponsor so make sure you stop by you
know and spend some time with Bruce he's
a good guy I want to encourage you all
to spend as much time in the city of New
Haven and on the campus of Yale
University I'm always pretty proud of
our pizza if anything you know for a new
haven so you'll be getting a lot of that
this week I know there's more than a
couple pubs and there's a pub crawl
tonight so it should be able to keep
most of you out of trouble but not
necessarily all of you out of trouble
Sam thanks a lot for coming and I'm
going to turn this over to the president
of SB NHC jean-marc gan yong thanks
thank you Tim and again welcome to
spinach 2012 or ace PSP NHC I'd like to
first take the opportunity to take tank
yale university and the yale peabody
museum of natural history for hosting
this year's conference and we'll hear
from the director of the museum dr.
Briggs and the approval from the
university dr saloon salluvii very soon
I also want to take obviously a moment
to thank them Susan and the entire local
organizing committee for doing such a
great and professional job to make us
feel at home here at Yale and in New
Haven and for putting a such a great
program for all of us the team has Tim
as mentioned it's totally relevant
emerging technology and innovation in
Natural History collections management
I'm pretty sure you will all find
something in there that will feed your
excitement for the rest of the year and
we'll bring you back next year in in
this great venue that spinach is as Tim
mentioned approximately 15 pretty much
certain it's 15 countries represented
that's fine that just wonderful we have
a great delegation from Denmark so if
you guys want to do the wave you can do
the wave there because there's 15 I
believe from Denmark so there's enough
people for the way the Netherlands of
course with the very strong
representation there we have Finland
this year and Belgium came back thank
you Germany is tan in company we have
grease that may be first Sweden not new
but thank you for being there obviously
great britain is here with us on Doris
under us right there so this is
Thank You Claudia for being with us here
and another new one is Kenya so we've
got can't see but that's wonderful
that's trail yeah of course Japan you've
got a couple of representatives from
Japan right there and well I can't
forget US and canada but i may have
forgotten another country did I okay so
I think they're all there wonderful so
of course i'd like to say special
welcome to the new members and the first
time participant the spinach conference
i especially want to recognize for
people today as part of them and it's
the awardee of the fitzgerald travel
grant there's Rachel sergeant from the
JFK University Museum Rachel you are
right there okay on the left-hand side
we have Megan toner of the Denver
Botanical Gardens all right middle there
and we have entra Papa trapaga sorry
from the University of California at
Berkeley right there I told her to stand
up so here we go and we have Nixon
Otieno from Kenya may not have traveled
the most distance but has worked very
hard to be here so welcome to you all
and I certainly encourage the new
members and and the all participants to
take great advantage of all the oral and
poster presentations workshops and all
the special events that we put that the
local organizing gravity has put
together it's a it's a formal setting
will have formal presentations but we're
not such a formal society we do have we
do like to have fun so introduce
yourself to people around do the
networking don't be shy you know we will
help you connect with the right people
so that
in terms of your career you can find the
right tools to move along there and
that's this world there and it's an
exciting year for those who don't know
you'll hear about it at the annual
business meeting so i encourage you to
be there will be talking about the
strategic plan will have the regular
business thing but we'll try to keep
that short so that we can actually talk
about our strategic plan which is there
I will be there is being developed to
better serve our members and the Natural
History collections community at large
so lunch is included so there's no
reason you can't be there it's Friday
lunchtime and the program will tell you
where that will take place so on this
I'd like to extend my warmest welcome to
you all wish you a very productive and
very enjoyable conference and please
feel free to approach any of us older
people and come with questions older I
mean in the society there and ask any
questions you may have get involved with
some of our or all of our committees we
are a great functional society because
we're all volunteers putting our effort
and knowledge and experience into this
society so you're all welcome thank
so now it's my pleasure to introduce the
director of the Peabody Museum Derek
Briggs
good morning folks thank you Tim I'm not
quite sure whether I should try to
channel Marlon Brando or Julie Andrews
this morning but I normally come to the
Schubert once a year to listen to the
Yale opera and Tim said this is your
chance to sing but rest assured I'm not
going to because of course I'm here to
welcome you on behalf of the yale
peabody museum to this 27th annual
meeting of the society although i guess
judging by the rather subdued demeanor
of some of you we did a pretty good job
welcome you last night in the whole of
dinosaurs at the museum were pleased
very pleased and proud to be hosting
this meeting i know were following in
some fairly large footsteps at the
Natural History Museum in London the
Canadian Museum of Nature the american
museum the Smithsonian the Netherlands
Center for biodiversity but as you've
heard of course one statistic we can
claim above all those other institutions
is that we have the largest spinach
meeting so far
and I know that part of this at least is
a reflection of the organizational
skills of my colleagues at the Peabody
the local organizing committee indeed
it's a privilege and a genuine pleasure
to work with such a professional and
talented and indeed convivial group of
people so it's fair to say that Yale
University continues to be a remarkable
steward of its collections which extend
well beyond the Peabody's Natural
History Holdings to its two major art
galleries and if you get a chance I
encourage you to go and visit they're
very close to this point the library's
the medical school the collection of
musical instruments but Peabody museum's
collections of 12 to 13 million
specimens are housed of obviously in new
haven but also add yells west campus and
will be delighted to show you or some of
you at least that facility on Friday
afternoon the environmental science
center which opened in 2001 next door to
the public museum houses entomology the
herbarium paleobotany living on fossil
invertebrates vertebrate zoology and
vertebrate paleontology is in an
adjacent building and the vision of that
building which has worked so well is to
hold the collections essentially across
the corridor from the research labs so
there's ready access to materials for
teaching and research the west campus
facility Yale acquired in 2007 there we
have some forty percent of our
collections including our museum archive
historical scientific instruments and
most of our anthropology materials in
what's essentially newly furbished and
being furbished space and we have the
special collections from most of the
people these other museum divisions out
there as well so it's a place where we
can accommodate material we have in
space for on the main site
the vision there is rather different
it's more but by no means exclusively on
the collections per se so the west
campus is the venue of Yale's nascent
Institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage which will incorporate
new centers for digitization and
conservation that will serve all the
university's collections so a
collaboration across these various
holdings of Yale so I'm confident of
course that you're going to continue to
enjoy this week at the heart of our
agenda are caring and sharing so
developing and delivering new methods of
conserving our collections and making
the information associated with our
holdings as widely available as possible
a major part of what this society is
about is no less in my view than
reinventing the interface between the
objects in our care and the end-user at
the result well I think in the future
many more people will use museum
collections but for most new users it
will be via images and information on
the web so this is the ultimate dream of
a museum person many more visitors more
scientific results but no increase in
the impact on the objects enjoy the
meeting
now it's my pleasure to introduce the
provost of Yale University Peter
salivate
thank you Tim welcome everyone on behalf
of president richard levin and myself
welcome to Yale welcome to New Haven and
welcome to the shubert theatre I know
President Levin would have loved have
been here to greet you himself and he
apologizes that he's not here but I am
here to say that we hope you have a
wonderful experience on the el campus
and in our great city I will say one of
the historic things you could do here in
the Shubert theater if you stay over the
weekend until Monday I is to participate
in a great American tradition
particularly those of you from
international locations and that is to
hear a willie nelson concert he's coming
here on Monday we're just thrilled that
we have 400 plus museum professionals
here for this conference it's a great
honor for us and I know that we will
learn from you by your being here I'm
very much looking forward to talking to
Derek and Tim after conference ends and
hearing more from them about what you
all are doing and your ideas for ways in
which L can do what we do better we're
really very proud of the collections
that this university has when we think
of the mission of the University
generating new knowledge transmitting
disseminating knowledge primarily
through teaching but a third mission
really is the preservation conservation
of you could say collections of
knowledge itself and we do that through
the British art center the university
art gallery the Peabody Museum the
Sterling library the by Nicki library
and the collection of musical
instruments all of these are our
fabulous collections and I do hope you
have the time to see some of them while
you are here I know that there are some
organized tours of these collections I
was Dean of yale college for four and a
half years and one of the questions I
used to ask our students is why do
universe
cities have collections such of these as
such as these it was really interesting
you you would think that's not a
difficult question for Yale and graduate
to answer but they would pause and they
would say well maybe it's it's what Yale
gives to the community it's for New
Haven and visitors they come to the
community and they want to go to a
museum and so they go to a university
collection do you say well yes that's
one of the things those that we do by
having those collections but that's not
the primary reason and they think for a
minute they take yeah that's right when
when our parents come for family weekend
and they get you know they begin to get
under our skin and we need to find them
something to do we send them off to the
Peabody or to the Art Gallery to the
Yale Center for British art when you
take well yeah your parents I'm sure
enjoy visiting those collections but
that's only you know that's just one
reason why we have them finally someone
will say well could they be for us say
yes those collections are actually here
for you they are part of your education
and we have tried in recent years to
reinforce that theme by promoting a kind
of idea of teaching through collections
and so even when you're teaching
something that is directly relevant to
the collection the history of British
art in the L Center for British art or
something about Natural History you know
paleontology bring them to the Great
Hall dinosaurs etc that's obvious but
what we're trying to encourage is our
faculty to teach through the collections
in less obvious ways so I'm a
psychologist who for many years taught
the introductory psychology course and
when we were studying mental health and
illness one of the ideas I had was to
show them representations of mental
illness in art for example in the self
portraits of Van Gogh and that's the
kind of idea we have
behind teaching through the collections
what in our collections might illuminate
the teaching of an idea of a concept of
a time in place that could be could be
enhanced by showing it as well as
telling it I did want to focus just on
one new initiative and Derrick mentioned
it in his comments a few moments ago and
that is this new Institute for the
preservation of cultural heritage out on
our west campus I do hope you'll visit
West Campus I know there's an organized
trip out there it's about 15 minutes
from here it was the old campus of the
bear pharmaceutical company which moved
its rd operations primarily to Germany
and we then purchased this campus it's
about a million and a half square feet
of space on about 125 acres it doubles
Gail's footprint and it immediately
allowed us to open up new laboratories
for primarily for interdisciplinary
science but it allowed us to do some
other things there's a huge
manufacturing facility out there which
is a big horizontally organized space
where as you have heard we have moved
much of the aspects of our collections
that were not on public display create
browsable storage essentially out there
but through a gift from Lizbet rousing
and Peter Baldwin of 25 million dollars
we will now be able to establish this
Institute where we will be able to join
essentially organize the scientific
basis of conservation and preservation
with the practice of conservation and
preservation and use yells own
collections as the substrate as the
laboratory for working both in
scientific and practical ways on
conservation issues we have organized
the Institute around essentially three
activities a digitization core that will
look at the way in which conservation
preservation
be enhanced through digitization a
Conservation Corps which will include
both science and practice of
conservation and a third Institute that
will host educational programs and the
dissemination of this information both
through the web as well as through
interactions with universities and other
kinds of collections throughout
throughout the world so we're very
excited about this we just hosted a kind
of workshop some of you may have
attended that gave rise to a sense of
what the mission of this institute
should be and what we should look for in
its first director so that's just a
quick update on what's happening at Yale
today I I do hope you'll take advantage
of being here and see some of these
activities during your visit we're so
fortunate to have you here and we
welcome you here I thank Derek and Tim
and the others have been involved in
pulling all of this together thank you
for coming for joining us I hope you
have some time to spend on the Yale
campus and in the city of New Haven and
even if you don't I do hope you'll come
back for more leisurely weekend with us
you're always welcome here we look
forward to seeing you again at Yelp and
in the city of New Haven thank you very
much
thank you Peter SP NHC conference
participants welcome to New Haven Yale
University and the Peabody Museum of
Natural History I am Susan butts your
conference co-chair along with Tim white
I hope that I have the opportunity to
meet all of you at some point during
this conference this morning I have a
great pleasure to introduce our keynote
speaker author Carl Zimmer Carl is the
award-winning author of 12 books on
science including topics in evolution
microbiology neuroscience and biology
his written hundreds of articles for the
New York Times National Geographic time
scientific america and science and was
the senior editor for discover his books
on e coli and viruses will make you
rethink your existence on a planet
dominated by microbes and might just
make you feel tiny his most recent book
science ink tattooz of the science
obsessed explores the devotion of
scientists to the objects of their
admiration via tattoos I'm certain that
car would be delighted to see all of
your natural history tattoos at some
point during this during this conference
Carl's keynote address from the page to
the pixel science writing goes online
we'll discuss his successes and failures
in taking science writing into the
digital realm as a society where
continue about continually evaluating
our use of digital media as a way to get
to disseminate knowledge and best
practices which is accessible to current
and future members regardless of their
ability to attend our annual meetings
with this in mind we're webcasting the
morning sessions car will be happy to
entertain questions after his talks
there are microphones in the front with
attendance and please join me in
welcoming our keynote speaker Carl
Zimmer
morning I'm just gonna get this set up
there we are great thank you thank you
for for coming out this morning I went
Susan and chris norris at and tim asked
me if I would come give a talk to you
guys this was some time ago and and then
they said well you need a title and
maybe an abstract and I came up with a
pretty innocuous sounding title but my
thoughts on these issues about about
journalism about the internet about sort
of how our communications across society
including museums of chain have changed
over the years it's evolved so so if I
had had an opportunity to to re title
this morning's talk I would call what
Chuck Norris and tapeworms taught me
about the future of journalism science
and civilization and and I promise you
it will all make sense by the end of our
talk so I I wanted to talk to you about
my own experiences but also try to kind
of weave it in with some some thoughts
about museums because for me as a
science writer museums are an essential
part of my world really I didn't start
out as a scientist I went to Yale here
as an undergraduate but I was an English
major and so I was reading about whales
but not in a biology class I was taking
a Melville class luckily after getting
out of college a couple years later I
got a job as an assistant copy editor at
a science magazine called discover and
there I discovered that I was really
enjoying learning about new scientific
research
and actually writing about it sort of
figuring out how to take research which
could be quite impenetrable in a journal
or at a scientific conference and being
able to tell a story that that anybody
could read so this is a cover from I
believe its 1993 not long after I
started and down at the bottom that's
actually called a mailing label so there
actually was a time when you know they
would stick these things on it would go
through the mail and actually that was
really the only way that you could get
discover magazine or go to a newspaper
stand the information was was locked in
there now it what was what made that so
precious was that that was a place where
where readers could be learning about
scientific progress and I would you know
in the 20 years that I've been writing
about science I think it's been I just
feel very lucky in that it's been an
amazing time to be writing about science
whether you're writing about people
looking back to the dawn of the universe
or looking back to the dawn of our own
lineage we know things now that we just
didn't know 20 years ago we couldn't
even think we could know and so it's
been wonderful to write about it but you
know the way that we science writers
write about science has changed a lot
and so I'll give you just one example of
how things have changed so here's a
still from King Kong and he's holding a
terrace or maybe watching king kong got
me curious about pterosaurs as a kid I
don't know maybe going to museum and
looking it up at one up and on the
ceiling kid I don't know but all I know
is that at some point within about three
years of starting working at discover
where I was writing features and so on I
just wondered well what's going on with
pterosaurs these days
and it's nice to have a job where you
can actually ask that question now it
wasn't actually easy to to find an
answer I couldn't just take to this
computer and say what is going on with
pterosaurs that wouldn't work I mean we
had computers but they weren't hooked up
to anything so what did I do I went to a
museum I was working in New York and so
I made a few inquiries up at the
American Museum of Natural History
turned out that there was someone
getting his PhD up there named Alexander
kellner from Brazil he's back in Brazil
now but at the time he was working on
some amazing fossils of pterosaurs and
I'll never forget going up to the museum
and this is a place I had been going to
many times since I was a kid going
through the entrance going through the
main exhibits and then kellner met me in
that public space and he said good to
meet you come with me and we walked down
a hallway past you know thousands of
kids and he sort of turns next to some
diorama of a bear or something and
brings out a key opens a secret door and
we go in and really I mean I know this
may be where you folks work but for but
for for the rest of us it really is an
astonishing experience to go behind to
where all the stuff is and so I nice tan
like I say I still remember that and
calendar took me to his office where he
had all of his pterosaur fossils and he
would say well here's a really
interesting sculpt and just handed to me
and so the whole experience was just
wonderful and and then and I was sitting
here thinking like well nobody nobody
outside of this you know back room in
this museum really knows about this and
I'm going to get to write about it so
what I wrote was a cover story for
discover on you know latest ideas on
terrace or biology where they were
warm-blooded could they walk on the
ground how much were they like birds all
these these fascinating things
I publish it in a magazine and it goes
on to newsstands now this picture was
taken I think in the 50s but you know
things hadn't changed that much in the
90s the the paintings that we
commissioned you could only find them in
that magazine the photographs we took
they were in that magazine or there were
slides that someone kept in a folder in
her office and that was it and you know
once once it came off of the once it
came off of the newsstand the only place
you could find it that information was
in a library you had to hunt that issue
down maybe go to a photocopying machine
and and photocopy it that was how
information float and it was a very
one-way experience you know I would
write a story and then it would take
months for it to show up up in the
magazine and then people would read it
and then maybe a month later maybe there
was someone to write letter to the
editor probably not so you had no idea
what people thought of it you had no
idea how many people read it you knew
nothing you were just sending
information often to avoid so since then
since working at discover I have kind of
gone off and written on my own i'm still
a contributing editor discover but i
have started to write at other places
like the new york times for example and
as Susan mentioned been writing books
all in that very old media kind of way
that the flow of information goes in the
in that same direction whether you're
talking about books or newspapers or
magazines or at least it did while I was
working at discover a scientist who I
was talking to I was trying to write
about his research on what it's like
when black holes collide and he said
well if you could get on the internet
you could go to my web page and you
could see an animation i did of a
computer simulation
and I didn't know what he was talking
about and it took you know the computer
people at the magazine some time to
figure out what was going on and we
actually like rigged up a computer to
the internet and used a program Netscape
to look at things and it was quite
astonishing but I didn't think at the
time that that's where people would be
reading my stuff I just thought it was a
great place to find information to then
put in that on that piece of paper then
when in that one one direction out
nevertheless you know I like I started
to set to set up an author website in
about 12 years ago now gosh but again
you know when we were when we science
writers would do that we weren't really
thinking like well this is where we're
going to be we were going to exist
digitally it was just a place to kind of
you know put our clip so that editors
would know what we do and just you know
have have a little presence a little toe
hold on the internet but my first clue
that things were going to be really
different I think came when I discovered
that there were people who had websites
that they get update every day they
didn't have to go through some hideous
code and and risk shutting down their
entire site they could they could just
updated constantly and they were having
conversations they were having having
had a very personal voice in what they
were writing these things were called
blogs and so I started experimenting
with that because I felt that you know
newspaper articles magazine articles
there they were satisfying in some ways
but it was kind of hard to put your
personal voice into it here it's all
your personal voice there's no editor
there's no
publisher there's no printer basically
when you're ready to publish you press a
button and you've published one thing
that really surprised me about this
experience was how different it was from
that one-way flow i mentioned to you
where people would get a magazine and
read it and that was basically the end
of it as far as you knew things have a
way of spreading on the internet and
that's a good thing and sometimes a bad
thing I'll talk about the good first so
here's an here's an example I I'm
somewhat obsessed with parasites wrote a
whole book about them and after I wrote
the book I discovered that there was a
cool parasite that I had totally
overlooked which is a wasp that uses
cockroaches as hosts for their babies
and they lay eggs on on the in the belly
of the cockroach the eggs crawl in and
eventually they pop out like that
getting the cockroach to put up with
this involves actually a little brain
surgery they put their stinger in the
head of the cockroach and inject certain
chemicals that make the the cockroach
essentially a zombie this turned out to
be quite a popular and and I could I was
interesting as I could track it and and
it would go in all sorts of unexpected
ways there was there weren't like set
boundaries like oh well this is a
science publication and people who are
interested in science shall read it and
that's the end of it it radiated which
which to me now i think is incredibly
important that if you can if you can
write about science communicated about
science and get that information to
radiate that's a victory and so for
example there's a website called boing
boing which is a wonderful eclectic mix
of technology and culture and science
and all sorts of different things and so
they got a big kick about it out of it
and so they talked about it linked back
to it but it wasn't just that sort of
thing there was there's a band in los
angeles that was so inspired they're
called super duper and they were so
inspired by this
story of this wasp but they actually
wrote a song about like a I think it was
kind of like a girlfriend who you know
controls the singers mind or something
like that anyway but they name of the
wasp is ambulance compressa and they
actually are singing at / looks
compressa and they're these night clubs
which i think is so cool but but even
cooler than that to get back to the
zombie theme is that people who make
video games I'm not sure exactly where
they picked it up along the way I think
it might have been through Boing Boing I
don't know but anyway there were links
coming back to my blog from video game
design forums where people saying have
you heard about this wasp this would be
an awesome character for video game and
it actually is one I haven't played this
one I don't know if they're any gamers
out there but aunty looks compressa is
in this game called dead rising so
that's just an example of the surprises
about how things can spread thanks to
this new system you get feedback
sometimes good and sometimes not so good
so this is when I was writing about a
court case about teaching evolution in
school yeah you can be sure of this Carl
the reason you cannot see how wrong you
are is that the god of this world Satan
has blinded your eyes to the truth may
God have mercy on your soul which is
pretty intense to get as a blogger I
honestly do not think that Satan is that
interest in the blogosphere but I could
be wrong in any case but this
illustrates actually something a very
important fact it's very important to me
especially because just simply because I
write a lot about evolution creationist
organizations are very well organized in
the United States and they took to the
Internet a long time ago so here for
example is the institution of creation
research which has been in existence
since the 60s and they've been on the
web I believe since at least the 90s
there's a very slick website where you
can learn about things like
au jus dinosaur bones fit flood a new
catch up fossils found in Arlington
Texas contains plenty of clothes that
are best explained by notes flood it's
on the internet you know people think
that things are on the internet are true
this is this is just a habit we fall
into and so if you have a nice website
with great typography people are going
to say well I read about it and so it
must be true even if someone is trying
to claim that fossils that are million
years old were actually laid down a few
thousand years ago now that being said
that's not a cause to say oh I hate the
internet and I'm going to run away and
pretend it doesn't exist and there have
been great examples of people not taking
that attitude so for example this is
just a grab of a page from a site called
panda's thumb which was actually started
by people who had been on newsgroups for
along to discussion groups for a long
time on the internet they decided to
take advantage of the tools that were
coming available blogging tools and so
on and they set up this site which has
been around for years now and it's a
really great resource for rebutting this
kind of creation it's nonsense so so
while I was seeing the value of this in
many different ways both in terms of
editorial freedom in terms of the the
value of rebutting misinformation and so
on my peers in traditional media didn't
quite know what I was getting into
because there weren't that many bloggers
at the time and so if you blogged you
tended to be stamped with a stereotype
that you were actually doing it in your
pajamas perhaps in your parents bed but
that basement I have logged on occasion
in my pajamas but I've also written for
The New York Times in my pajamas because
I'm a free
answer I work at home it's okay but but
that stigma that somehow blogging was
not quite legitimate I suppose had a lot
of strength when newspapers and
magazines were really incredibly
profitable there actually was a time
when newspapers were incredibly
profitable but that's not now I didn't
know that when I started fooling around
with blogging you know in 2003 I did not
know that the next decade was really
going to see a terrifying collapse of a
whole industry so this is advertising
revenue which in case you you know you
can't have our time seeing that number
the the earliest year that's 1950 that's
like Truman okay so newspaper ad
revenues climbed quite handsomely up
until nineteen ninety a bit of a dip but
regained in two thousand but since then
it's been crashing I mean that slope is
almost vertical now and we're back
basically to nineteen fifty all of that
advance has been wiped out and so people
who were actually employed in newspaper
publishing are vanishing breed as well
and this this affects how science is
covered unfortunately so you know when
newspapers are trying to economize and
slim down they get rid of their science
sections they get rid of their science
writers I'm really grateful to still be
writing for The New York Times they they
here they have really stood by their
science section but the same can't be
said for a lot of other places so things
have have flipped and this is a pretty
striking graph and it's something to
bear in mind when you're thinking about
how you get the information in your
museums to people these are results of a
survey from the National Science
Foundation where they asked people what
do you get your information about
science for example about specific
scientific issues
the internet almost half of people in
2001 said the internet and now it's well
over half do where as you can see
newspapers is fading off there when
people have questions they about science
they go online and they can find all
sorts of things there they can find
creations websites that can find article
in the new york times they can find
museum websites there's all sorts of
stuff that they can find but that's
where they're going now it was very
interesting to discover blogging and to
kind of get into that and make that kind
of part of my life but it seems now that
like the one constant with the online
world is it's change itself in other
words there are more and more systems
that gets set up for transmitting
information in all sorts of different
ways and these are systems that are
growing so rapidly that even if it
sounds funny like Twitter you can't just
pretend it doesn't exist you know when
hundreds of millions of people are
getting their information someplace
that's something that you have to pay
attention to if what you're interested
in is information and I think you know
we journalists are and people that
museums are as well this makes things
very complicated I start to think about
ecology now so you know before I you
know I was trained in science writing
when it was just this very simple little
chain you you fight you do some research
for a story you publish it it goes out
there people read it and then I don't
know they put their magazine the
recycling I mean that's sort of the life
cycle of information but now things are
bouncing all over the place so if you if
I write an article it might end up being
in part of a book so i might blog about
it and there might be some extra
information that i wasn't able to put in
the article or the book i don't know
then someone asked if i'd be on their
podcast on the gardening that show you
sure why not we talked about it that
gets linked to some other blog which
just radiates all around and running
around
the hope is that you as a science writer
actually make some money the process
which is that that why that I have that
amazon.com is that hopeful convergence
of all arrows sometimes that's true
sometimes it's not but in any case the
reality is that managing this this web
gets to be a major part of everyone's
job one of the most interesting things
to me now is that is how books which for
a long time was kind of like the last
holdout in terms of what was traditional
about media has changed I mean actually
I've been hearing people saying oh
ebooks are going to change publishing
for well over ten years and I generally
didn't believe a thing the people would
say about that usually they were trying
to get you to pay a thousand dollars to
come to their very fancy seminar where
they tell you all about the future of
ebooks on maybe a Palm Pilot but now
there are the machines that can handle
it and you know the New York Times Book
Review when it shows you the best
sellers ebooks as its own category in
many cases now new books will sell more
copies in new books will sell more
copies electronically then say in
hardback and not only that but like
blogging you don't necessarily need an
official publisher you can do it
yourself I mean if you know how to use
them fairly fairly simple software you
can actually start self-publishing and
there are all sorts of really innovative
companies that are starting up like the
Atavist for example which is publishing
pieces that are about 20,000 words long
which just had no place ten years ago
they were way too long for a magazine
article way too short for a book which
is silly I mean that's just somehow
saying that that a certain format is not
allowed just because our business model
can't handle it well this one can and
the out of this is actually publishing a
lot of really interesting science so I
encourage you to check that out
I've actually gotten so fascinated with
ebooks that I on some other colleagues
have started up a what we'd like to call
a science ebook review called download
the universe where we're exploring all
of these new experiments and so so while
it's a while there's a lot of complexity
to this ecosystem it's something that's
fascinating to be a part of and to watch
evolve so so the I was thinking about
this I was developing the working on my
talk so so how do museums fit into all
this so as I had mentioned before you
know for me museums as a journalist
where this incredibly important
reservoir of information of research of
expertise and so on and I've you know
interviewed many people at museums over
the years museums traditionally hold on
to this these resources and their
collections put some of them in an
exhibit maybe you know publish a book a
book that's for sale in the gift shop
and not not much else I mean that was
the traditional model of the museum and
it's a very valuable one but I'm sure I
don't need to tell you that the the
digital environment presents a lot of
opportunities for museums so I just want
to talk about a few things that I think
are really interesting for one thing you
can open up your collections and this is
important not just for scientists I want
to point out it's it's important for
well for journalists for example if I
had wanted to do research on pterosaurs
who knows maybe I wouldn't have met
Alexander kellner when I started that
story if I hadn't met him that one guy I
might have just missed out on a great
story but if there's the more spread out
the information is the more available it
is the more likely it is the reporters
are going to be able to find out
it and so maybe calendar could have done
3d scans like what did you morph does
and have them online for people to check
out and look at the references and so on
that's a it's a wonderful opportunity
for connecting with journalists but also
with everyone I mean you know when I'm
talking with my girls or ten and eight
and we get into some discussion
sometimes you know sometimes you need to
pull up a skull on the computer screen
and you can do that which is great
that's the kind of conversations after
my kids maybe you do too ebooks actually
I think are something that museums are
in a great position to take advantage of
and this is something that really only
occurred to me recently while working on
download the universe a couple of the
books that I actually like the most were
put together by museums so on the left
is something from the Exploratorium in
San Francisco called color uncovered
which is essentially an an e-book well
it's it's more like an app that is like
an exhibit about color that you might
see at the exploratorium but they don't
just kind of cut and paste an exhibit on
to an app screen they they understand
what works well in a nap and what
doesn't and so it's a wonderful
experience you actually end up reading a
lot there are great illusions that they
have on there they have they've and it's
all wonderfully integrated and and it's
something that you can explore and come
back to and explore again I particularly
love the detail about how Monet had
cataracts when they got older and this
this app talks about how that changed is
painting because of the light that was
coming in was changing in terms of the
color that could get through and they
actually did a procedure where they took
out just removed one of his lenses and
so all of a sudden UV light started
coming in that I
and you can actually look at paintings
that he tried to paint with that I and
you can actually see how some flowers
that have UV coloring actually look
different there than in his previous
paintings which is the sort of thing
that'll go to museum and I would read
about and learn about and be great but
now the museum is coming to me another
example is something called the internet
or da Vinci anatomy which was actually
in conjunction with an exhibit which i
believe is on now the Royal Collection
in England color on covers is free
Leonardo da Vinci things like 13 bucks
so it's you know you got to pay for it
but it's worth it it's it's quite
magnificent in the way that it
integrates leonardo's anatomical
sketchbooks with with with interactive
anatomical features with interviews with
anatomist seeeeee or with museum people
it's all brought together in a really
lovely way so so there's is one place
where I think that museums have a really
interesting opportunity to explore you
know even YouTube can can be incredibly
useful if you know how to use it right
this is something called the known
universe or the American Museum of
Natural History took lots of the data
that they have there the Hayden
Planetarium and used it essentially to
create a kind of trip through the
universe you start in the Himalayas you
pull up from there you zoom out the
Earth's gets very small solar system
gets very small and pretty soon you're
looking at galaxies and the whole
structure of the universe it's it's very
nicely done and as you can see at the
bottom there I just checked this
yesterday 10 million over 10 million
people have seen this so if you think
about this as an extension of how many
people come to see the material in your
Museum it seems to me like this really
extends that mission magnificently
but then sometimes Chuck Norris comes
into your life so Chuck Norris for those
of you who might not be aware of this
perhaps those are you in Denmark let me
explain that that that unique American
phenomenon that is Chuck Norris Chuck
Norris was a was a martial arts guy who
got into movies and he was in a show
called Walker Texas Ranger so he was you
know basically one of our you know big
macho action heroes who would you know
wear shirts like that and then he got
into being a pundit and actually he
became a pretty pretty prominent
columnist you know very very
conservative politics is mostly what he
sticks to now the reason I bring this up
is because I read a column about the
brain and a few months ago I read a very
interesting and disturbing review and a
journal Nature Reviews neurology about a
condition called neurocysticercosis
which is basically what happens when you
eat say some contaminated pork which has
tapeworm take burns in it and they get
confused instead of going there at the
stage where they need to be actually in
a pig instead they're in a human and
they you know we think of tapeworms is
filling up the intestines well this is
even worse they actually end up as cysts
in your brain this is spooky and
grotesque and all but it's a serious
public health crisis it's in this review
for example it was estimated that five
million people around the world suffer
from epilepsy because of
neurocysticercosis and this is something
that could be eliminated this is not is
not a particularly big challenge this is
not like Gingrich malaria or something
like that we could get rid of this
it's just that this affects mostly poor
people and we all know how that goes
when it comes to medicine so I write
this column about this disease and about
this this issue and it I noticed that
it's quite it's got legs you know it's
radiating out there people are basically
they're on Twitter or I don't know I
haven't can post or other places saying
oh my god tapeworms in the brain that's
about as far as their their reaction to
it gets but the like they just their
their minds are blown which which you
know it is good if it's getting their
attention you know I hope they will
actually like read through it and see
that this is a public health issue that
that if we focus on it could actually be
helped so then like a couple days later
this comes to my attention and this is
chuck norris's column and this latest
one was called beware what gets inside
your head I'm going to read this year so
this is like sort of a Dear Abby format
down in the italics there it says Chuck
I learn a lot from your series on lyme
disease i got about as far as that i was
like oh okay Texas Walker microbiologist
whatever and the dangers of tick bites
speaking of infectious diseases I had a
science befriend tell me tapeworms can
tap inside of our brains leading to all
sorts of maladies ever heard of that
signed squirming in Spokane and Chuck
says this issue is not for the faint at
heart yet it should be read by everyone
everywhere MSNBC reported that this
health problem is a quote hidden
epidemic the network's report was based
on a maid 2012 discover magazine science
scientific investigation that was
subtitled parasitic worms leave millions
of victims paralyzed epileptic or worse
so why is anyone doing anything
eradicated and then the it's quite a
long column the rest of it because it's
basically
by alcone cut-and-paste dumped in there
done unfortunately that's another aspect
of of being a science writer these days
is that you're in the interim
information is very fun jable so you can
work very hard to to craft a column
that's going to to balance all of these
things you know that grotesqueness of
this disease with the public health
importance and so on and interview
people read papers and it can take about
five seconds for someone to just grab
what you've done and just run with it
which incense isn't all that bad because
I mean because he lifted all that for me
I'm it's accurate I could say so I guess
that's good but the problem is when you
get to the the comments and you just
feel like like you just are just going
off in a really bad direction there are
far more than 1500 to 2000 people in the
united states affected f heated well
this is off sick i'll just say with
these worms on the brain a proof of that
is simple how many registered democrats
are there so that i'm just going to show
you a few of these this is out of I
don't know maybe 200 comments or
something like that Hannity rush
Huckabee Palin and Chuck notes I'll
stroke clear evidence of worm brain the
USA will see a huge increase in this
parasitic infection with the Democrat
Party importing all the illegal vote so
they can get so like illegal aliens are
like you know they're all bringing
tapeworms with them like zombies there's
this there was another discussion that
was part of this discussion was about
pigs and about how Pharaoh you know wild
boars are on the loose and they're going
to give tapeworms to everybody I don't
know how that happens but in any case
people were saying you know there wasn't
fair that they weren't able to use you
know I guess large automated weapons to
kill all these feral pigs so he was one
comma the UN the United Nations has
already been regulating our farmers
because washington wants them to has
signed a way our sovereignty to the you
now the UN and their environmental scan
prevent farmers from controlling wild
boar heard so we all have equal
opportunity to be carriers so the United
Nations is putting tape rooms in your
brain just want to make sure we're clear
now hi so I like this was happening and
you know Twitter is a wonderful place
kind of like let off steam so I at some
point I was like I just said on Twitter
like this is the weirdest moment in my
career of B of having a column lifted by
chuck norris which brought some people
from Twitter to the comment thread which
really got things interesting and so
this was I guess one of them Walker
Texas plagiarist which summoned up some
really interesting responses stole you
don't actually imagine that zimmer
invented tapeworms I didn't or was the
first person on earth to notice they
infect people's brains to do you I'd
call you idiotic accusations against
Chuck slander and libel to it just goes
on from there so so this gave me some
pause you know I because as you can tell
I'm quite enthusiastic about this is the
opportunities that the internet provides
but you know things can go in really
weird directions that are totally out of
your control now this is a big enough an
issue for me just as an individual
writer but for organizations you know
that are supposed to have kind of an
organizational voice that an
institutional voice like museums for
example this is a problem this Center
for Disease Control is another
institution and you know they tried to
like you know get into the social media
game and be hipped and so on and they
were quite clever with it they came up
with a website on the CDC
the cdc gov site about their zombie
preparedness plan they said okay what
are you going to do when the zombies
come are you going to be ready you know
do you have your kit do you have fresh
drinking water because I guess the
zombies will turn off the water supply I
don't I don't know but in any case it
was it was quite elaborate um and it was
on its own terms it was I thought it was
brilliant it got huge amounts of
attention and it was it was a funny way
of bringing people's attention two big
issues like preparedness disaster
preparedness which otherwise is really
hard to get people interested in I mean
it's like you know it's like broccoli or
something I mean people are not going to
be flocking online be like ooh I want to
see what's new and disaster preparedness
but so they went to town with this and I
think they were feeling pretty happy
about this up until maybe a week ago
because you may recall that all of a
sudden there were all these stories
about people cannibalizing each other
and just going berserk in Florida and
all these other places Newsweek actually
like put up a google maps showing you
know the zombie outbreak like oh look
you can click on all these different
things to see like the latest case of
someone dismembering somebody else or
something the definition of zombie was I
have to say was quite broad but but that
you know the CDC believe it or not got
kind of wrapped up into this because
Huffington Post decided that that you
know it was worth investigating whether
there was some kind of virus some sort
of zombie virus that was causing trouble
and so they they actually you know got
in touch with the CDC and the poor CDC
had to issue this statement
this is like a formal statement CDC does
not know of a virus or condition that
would reanimate the dead or that would
present zombie like symptoms wrote
agency spokesman David daigle and email
to the Huffington Post I mean you know
that is about as cold and distant a kind
of a you know interaction with the media
as you can imagine I mean he wouldn't
even get on the phone I'm gonna send you
an email and that's it I don't want to
have anything else to do with this
nevertheless as you can see the headline
ends up being zombie apocalypse CDC
denies denies existence of zombies
despite despite cannibal incidents you
know what do you expect from your
government I mean of course they would
deny this because they're letting the
pigs run loose um actually actually so
this became like really popular the you
can look at the numbers there you know
21,000 people sharing on Facebook and so
on and so forth and so another new site
the daily caller would not be outdone
and so they were reading actually stuff
at discover magazine about about
toxoplasma which is a single-celled
parasite that probably about a quart of
you have their brains it might subtly
adjust your personality but other than
that you're fine but the daily caller
called the CDC and demanded to know why
they weren't looking into toxoplasma as
an explanation because if toxoplasma
gets into a rat the rat is most it might
be more likely to be killed by a cat
because it loses the fear of cats cats
being the final host of toxoplasma so I
mean you you can see that's obviously
you know that's that's Ombey stuff right
there the CDC wouldn't even respond to
the daily caller which is what you just
don't want to do
so you know I you know I haven't gone
through my own Chuck Norris experience I
can sympathize with with the CDC I can
you know I understand you know some of
you and museums maybe a little bit
anxious about this but you know the
Internet's got not going away and you
can't pretend that things are not out
there and you can use these situations
for you know to be creative so this is
was my response it's kind of a you know
a little fact check on on all this a
zombie stuff and actually no I just
pointed out how silly it all was but I
also had an opportunity to get back to
some real science about those zombie
cockroaches about toxoplasma and so on
and so forth so you know you can try to
think about it as as jujitsu you know
try to take these opportunities to sort
of flip things around to what you want
to do it's it's it's never going to sort
of settle down to the way things used to
be but at the very least maybe if you're
dealing with this strange kind of
mutating outbreak that we call the
internet you can you can steer the the
outbreak in interesting directions so
thanks so much for coming and happy to
take any questions
so we have folks with microphones I
guess you can just raise your hand
you've all been zombified hi I'd like to
ask altima tlie do you think that there
is more good science information out
there now than there was previously even
with all of the interesting consequences
zombies and otherwise yeah so the
question was is there more good in
scientific emission information out
there now regardless of the zombies and
yes I mean I just think there's any way
you measure it there's a colossal amount
of information I mean you know just in
my work as a science writer I mean I
would have to go when i was at discover
in new york i would go to the new york
university library to go to their
science library because that was the
only place where I could get information
on what happened to be writing about you
know I live in guilford nearby I
sometimes come to use the libraries here
but only for certain specialized tasks
because there is so much good
information online you just need to know
how to find it because I would I would
while there's more good information I
would say that it's proportion it's
percentage of total information is going
way down and which makes it harder to
find the good stuff and and i think that
i think at this point one of the most
important thing that kids have to learn
is that not everything on the internet
is true in fact very little of it is
true and they need to develop the skills
to know what's garbage and what you can
rely on and and you know a lot of adults
are having hard times with that so so
that seems like the great information
challenge of our times to me
hi I wasn't scribbling fast enough and
didn't have my pencil out soon enough so
are you going to have somewhere we can
find all those lovely website address as
you head um sure sure sure uh let's see
um I will just go just go to my blog i
mean when i get home i'll just i'll post
this on there okay so later today I'll
do that hi I'm very much enjoyed your
talk I just want to say that I was just
curious if you could speak to I guess
the wiki's out there and the reason I
say that is because just coming out of
graduate school myself you know you go
to the library and they teach you how to
go online and find all these articles
and then you go home and spend hours and
every article you find you get the
abstract and then you have to pay a
certain fee or subscription and half the
time it doesn't work and so you know the
library is what I generally use but a
lot of its outdated so like you said you
go online what is actually up to date it
is very hard to tell if it's true or not
and you know your professors say Oh
we'll find peer-reviewed journals but
it's it is a challenge can you just
speak to that right yeah yes it's it's
definitely I mean the access to its it's
amazing that on the one hand that
scientific journals have finally
basically gone completely online and and
you know for me it's been amazing
watching that transformation but it is
coming definitely at quite a steep price
that being said you know more and more
there's more and more stuff that's that
is now open access at least like in our
in biology and medicine the subjects i
right about a lot some journals are just
open access from the get-go and in other
cases after six months the journal makes
it open access and also supposedly a lot
if you're funded by the NIH you're
supposed to deposit a copy of your paper
in a source called pubmed central so
so it's getting better and if you look
around you can find peer-reviewed open
access information and that and that's
important you know here it's not only
important in the United States even it's
far more important in you know a poor
country where scientists don't have big
university libraries you know it would
be better if they could get their hands
on the information to help them become
better scientists so but the trends are
all moving in the right direction I
think yes sir yeah wonderful talk I
wonder if you discuss the possible
benefits of science students reading
Moby Dick the benefits of science
students reading Moby Dick well I think
everyone would benefit reading Moby Dick
science students in particular would
benefit in several different ways
because it's you know I would say about
a quarter to a third of it is really
science writing it's not it's it's a
partly a novel and it's partly a big
book about whales and it's you know
beautiful science writing and and you
know I will sometimes dip into it to
kind of get the engine's going into
remember how someone who really knows
how to write can write about something
like a whale it's also fascinating
because it's it's it's pre Darwinian you
know he issued me all talked about the
debate about whether matt whales are
mammals are fish and he's like I'm
old-fashioned I'm going to call it a
fish and I'm gonna you know I'm going to
invoke Jonah for that so yeah on many
different levels science students should
read Moby Dick and lots of other
literature to help them learn how to
write I Carl I really enjoyed your talk
it's really helpful to us I'm back here
oh thank you thank you I hear your voice
all around yeah and speaking of coming
out of the dark is is there anything any
emerging system that's going to start to
that information on the web I think of
the way that we can all do likes now is
it foresee a time when it's possible
that if a professor
certain area like something it scores
some credibility points where if Chuck
Norris likes it maybe goes down some
credibility points so okay so will there
be a system where the presser likes some
information it gets upgraded and if
Chuck Norris like so it gets sound great
no I don't think so I just I you know
the Internet is just a great big complex
system and it's not going to be tamed
but it like I said before it offers
offers the opportunity of great
opportunities so you know a community of
people can can use it to to collectively
you know judge for themselves you know
what it you know sort good sources of
information and bad sources and so on I
think that's just actually just starting
where people are trying trying to do
that you know I've seen efforts like
that kind of get going and then peter
out and the new one gets going then it
Peters out and so the the internet is
littered with these abandoned attempts
to domesticate it so you know I do think
there's an opportunity for collective
work but but like I was saying before I
think I think a focus on the on the
individual reader really matters a lot
teach it you know teaching people how to
read stuff skeptically you know where
did the where's the source of that claim
is it footnoted what can I go to that
footnote and things like that you know
that's all part you know in a way it's
just a variation on what we were all
supposed to learn in school but it but
there has to be a focus on it for the
Internet age I think
yes first thanks for great demonstration
of the value of a Yale education money
well spent most of this audience or big
part of the audience is involved in
digitizing collections which would take
at first glance as making the
collections more accessible but you
found your way into the pterosaur
collection just by luck through a person
who knew a lot about that collection in
that that community of inquiry mm-hmm
have you seen or can you think of ways
that this enormous body of information
about the specimens digital images could
be made more interesting and more viral
in the absence of a peer-reviewed
journal article about that that somebody
might stumble over the the rationale for
the investment to digitize these
enormous collections is it's valuable to
the research community to make it more
accessible and we can also put pins on a
map showing where things come from but
that's still pretty low on the food
chain as far as the jesta belen firm
ation not sure I got that metaphor quite
right how can you think of a medium that
collection managers graduate students
researchers could ways that they could
take advantage of new new media to use
this this enormous catalogue more
effectively to transmit interest well
I've never been a big fan of just doing
something because you feel like you're
supposed to be doing it and there's a
lot of that online you know I saw that
with blogging for example so blogging
just started started because people just
wanted to do it you know they were
passionate amateurs really who started
the whole thing and and then after a
while blogging not so successful there
are so many people who were reading
blogs that you know for traditional
organizations you know magazines and
newspapers would command
they're they're writers to blog the
writers and editors had to blog and
we've decided that you need to blog you
like two times a day you know that's
what our consultants tell us so go do it
and it was awful it's just you know the
desperation just reeks off the screen I
mean so why were they doing it I mean
what was the goal there I mean it was I
mean it was it was based on a
fundamental misunderstanding of why
people were reading blogs in the first
place they weren't reading blogs so they
could get some sort of like you know
corporate self-promotion they're reading
it because they were interested what
someone had to say an individual so you
know I I guess my main advice would be
like really think clearly about what
your goals are I mean are you saying
like okay I want my goal my dream is for
you know all 300 million Americans to to
you know just work their way through my
butterfly collection yeah is that a
realistic expectation why would people
want to do that in the first place it
doesn't I mean the whole questionable do
you use Flickr or Facebook or so on is
really secondary to those more
fundamental issues thank you for the
wonderful talk I was wondering what is
your how do you envision a future if
there is any future for traditional
printing on paper and that contained
explosion of printing on internet so
what's the future of printing on paper I
think well you know I mean I just the
Susan just mentioned this book I
published called science inc which is
this slightly insane you know project
where I gathered all these tattoos of
scientists and wrote about the tattoos
and the scientists and the stories
behind them it was huge amount of fun
but it really had to be on paper you
know it would be ridiculous I mean that
started as a blog experiment but you
know the way I was conceiving of it it
had to be a beautiful object and
unfortunately my publisher sterling was
was all behind me
and the designers you know we had gold
stamp cover and all that it was great
fun but but there the thing is that
they're just I mean if you're if you're
not doing some pretty exotic project it
may just be easier faster simpler and
better business sense to publish it
digitally it just that just seems to be
where things are going partly because
it's easier to read things on devices
and I just I just don't see that
stopping it's kind of like it would be
like someone sort of at that top of that
newspaper curb its things are starting
to go down saying like well what's the
future everything's going to turn around
right and you know why should it I mean
you know once craigslist exists why
would you expect classified ads to
suddenly like turn around for no reason
so I do think that printed books are
going to become kind of a specialty item
and I speak as someone who has a house
full of books so you know what can you
do you spoke of uh could you might not
be much more of a conversation what are
your thoughts on anonymity and
attribution in this kind of conversation
so the question is what about anonymity
in terms of the conversation online I
can't make up my mind about that because
and this has been years that I've been
thinking about this I don't know the the
the pluses and the minuses are so
powerful so the minuses are that
anonymity let's gives people a kind of a
confidence to be nasty and vicious it's
like writing graffiti on a bathroom wall
you say horrible people will say
horrible things and and and the problem
is that even if a tiny percentage of
your commenters leave these awful
comments that's all that people see and
that people will think that that
represents the entire
community the entire conversation and so
you know some people have argued that
you know you have to have people use
their names to come out to not be
ashamed of publicly saying you know that
the UN is giving us tapeworms or
whatever and on the other hand I think
there are lots of situations where
anonymity is essential there are for
example some of the most interesting
blogs I'm not just talking about comet
errs I'm talking about like someone
writing a blog there was a blog that ran
for a long time that I really liked it
was written by an epidemiologist who was
highly critical of his or her I don't
know colleagues pointing out serious
problems in their field but he wanted to
say or she want stay anonymous just
because of the potential repercussions
so so I don't know I mean there might be
some sort of in-between thing there
there are experiments in sort of the
community kind of policing itself you
know if people are kind of way out of
line there's a way for like the whole
group of people who are reading the blog
or at the site to just say you know
that's not cool we're not going to
tolerate that so then it doesn't just
it's not doesn't come down to one person
writing the blog to decide who is worthy
and who isn't it's an important issue
and it's not going away okay great well
I'll be hanging around at the break so
anyway thank you
you